wir spielen Mario Party mit Sandra Siri
und einem Bot Sandra erklär du mal Mario
Party also da geht es quasi knapp und
kurz darum äh Sterne zu sammeln das ist
das Hauptziel und nach jeder Runde gibt
es quasi Minispiel oder die kommt er
Wirtschaften kannst du mit diesen Coins
kannst du z.B Items kaufen um näher an
den Stern zu kommen wir spielen
Minispiele durch Minispiele verdient man
Münzen man hat eine bessere Chance hat
sich ein Stern zu kaufen aber am Ende
gewinnt der mit den meisten Sternen gibt
aber am Ende noch so Zusatz Sachen wie
beispielsweise wer die meisten
Minispiele gewonnen hat wer am meisten
gelaufen ist etc und das Spielen Sandra
Siri und ich aus
wie ich boah ich nehme
krass hey kann man sich auch selber
nehmen serioja deswegen habe ich ja ich
habe
mit der abgesprochen dass die mich
reinbringen ins Spiel spielen Standard
map
König pulveraffen
weil du kannst in der Mitte auch voll
viel verlieren ich bin tatsächlich für
die ja
jetzt muss man wieder zwei Minuten
warten bis die Umfrage durch ist und
wenn die Umfrage durch ist mir trotzdem
das worauf Luca Lust hat
es ist so dicker ich bin einfach äh vor
Prophezeiungen 9000 ja es ist so mein
leicht seit dreieinhalb Jahren aber egal
10% sagen die Standardmap 90% sagen
andere Map bekommen dann nehmen wir die
hier sandra hat gesprochen König Bonbons
pulverfassine okay zehn rum oh wollen
wir 20 mach 100
ist zu schnell rum mach mal 15 bitte
20 Runden ja das geht voll schnell
vorbei weil wir nicht so viele sind vier
genauso wie sonst auch nee manchmal mehr
man muss immer zu viel wenn wir schon
mal zueinander gefunden haben Sirio auch
Zeit hat für mich sollten wir es auch
endlich mal auskosten mal andere Spiel
zu spielen
drückt die
2020 so los geht's du könntest du jetzt
nein dabei grinsender Smiley
Alter Maulwurf
Sonderangebote
hey es geht schon wieder los ne
Controller vielleicht drück mal x
okay oder falscher Controller Controller
wirklich
Playstation Controller oder was
ja ich werde jetzt so deinen kleinen
verfickten Arsch aufreißen Bruder du
weißt nicht wie dein Arschloch heute
brennen wird ich schwöre es dir Alter
ja Leute natürlich
nicht so viel Sinn
guck mal in der Mitte ist jetzt quasi 4
und wenn wir jetzt noch vier Mal auf so
einen
präsentiert für dich das ist ein Bonbon
nein
oh nein oh nicht dein Ernst nee
kommst du diese diese Bomben Teile
ach du meinst in der Mitte
ach so ja so Leute jetzt geht's los mit
Vorhersagen wir machen ein Minispiel
also bitte Vorhersage wer gewinnt Sandra
oder Siri Luca Peach weil jetzt gerade
ist es eins gegen drei Minispiel sandra
musste auf ihrer Seite die Teile
abschießen und ich muss
und wir sind im 3er-Team das Problem ist
dass wir mit einem Bot spielen und die
knallt wahrscheinlich überall hin ne bei
Sandra ist halt deutlich einfacher weil
sie alleine einfach abschätzen kann
Sandra du weißt wie du schießen damit y
halt dein Maul
geh doch weg von meiner Seite
hey das ist so ein scam wieder gewinnen
bei Peach junge rüber
ja so eine Tran
Mann
ich habe alle verloren
ey dicker Pitch fragt mich jetzt schon
ab Jungs was habe ich euch gesagt legt
euch niemals
nein Sandra du bist einfach scheiße in
dem Spiel es ist immer einfacher wenn
man alleine ist wir spielen mit dieser
dummen
die [__] mich so ab schon wieder diese
Peach Handy noch mal zwei
halt dein Maul dicker
hey Leute sollen normal oder soll ich
den Würfel nehmen
was heißt das erst wenn die drei da ist
dann explodiert der und dann krachts bei
uns allen also ich sage ganz ehrlich
oh mein Gott ist das schwer dicker ja
schafft er nicht
junge
einfach besser junge einfach besser und
das war echt schwer da seht ihr noch
Freunde
was passiert denn bei drei noch zwei
explodiert
drauf
Viereck boah so stark wirklich so stark
eine einsam
boah bleib ich auf diesem Ding drauf
lohnt sich nicht in den Stern also der
Typ hat noch zwei Mal dann ist vorbei
ach sterben nur die Leute auf der
Plattform
nein wir sterben nicht wir kriegen nur
paar Geld Coins Weg Leute ich bin mit
Peach und ein Team geht alle nicht auf
mich ich werde so verlieren oh nein aber
sowas mit Siri zu machen ist auch sehr
ehrlich mit sowas mit Luca zu machen das
kann nichts werden hä was laberst du
junge müssen diese Bulle nebeneinander
sein oder einfach auf der Map
nebeneinander
wo bist du Bruder
[Applaus]
hast du nicht genommen
ja ja
kein Bock mehr auf den Schmutz hier bin
sauer
gemacht
wenn ich Beziehung führen müsste mit
denen sagen wir einmal wenn du nur
bumsen ist einmal nur für bumsen einmal
nur für Beziehung
würde ich einmal weg knattern und
ja Daisy würde ich dann heiraten ich
würde ich würde glaube ich genauso
machen ich würde Daisy heiraten weil die
wird korrekter
knattern
kommt noch ein bisschen so schlampig
rüber also no frontaker ne ihr seid so
oberflächlich Jungs
ist ja auch Oberflächlichkeit eigentlich
nur aber überlegt mal Peach Alter wie
oft die immer von Mario Weg geht immer
zu Browser chillen und so
richtig oft ne
sagt doch immer und auch mal die chillen
nur aber ich glaube da gibt mehr
sie sagt immer die wurden ist klar
stimmt was meint ihr mit Game Sound ist
verpackt Leute
das auch gerade
ja was ist denn da so Rauschen mal
gucken ich muss vielleicht gucke ich den
Morgen Rauschen
warum denn das so ich schaue mir das
jetzt mal selber an mit meinem Stream
hier lass direkt auf Luca gehen was ist
denn das und was geht es denn Gegner aus
dem Brunnen Spritzen mit einmal
Wassertanken und kannst du fünf Mal
Spritzen
dann sollten wir es besser nicht mit
Luca spielen weil der kann das sehr gut
besser rauschen
alle nur am Meckern kämen die Ecke
kommen ich mache euch jetzt erstmal
ja dicker
genau
gar nichts steht ja schon da in diesem
Haus
oh mein Gott
ey ich habe einfach reingeschissen wir
haben nur eine Runde spielt man das
Scheiße
hey wer ist das denn ist die süße denn
oha die sind jetzt drei Mädels ja vier
boah die ist aber süß ne Rosalina Sound
des bodenlos ja ich weiß nicht wann
fliegt man ich habe ganz normal die
Switcher drin vielleicht ist HDMI Kabel
locker oder so ein bisschen leiser hier
hinten im Spiel Sound kaufen gehen
ah du spinnst
Yoshi Würfel genommen
oder nicht kaufen was sagt ihr nicht
kaufen wenn du ein Mann bist lässt das
gedrückt und drückst einfach randomix
nach unten geht nicht das heißt ich kann
nur hoch runter gehen dann mach Augen zu
Augen zu ja okay ich mache Augen zu okay
nichts gemacht
ich weiß aber ganz genau dass ihr das
auch nicht gemacht hättet doch ich hatte
gemacht
beim nächsten machen ja sowieso nicht
mehr
es gibt keine Mädels mehr super
aber der hat ein ganz guten Würfel
tatsächlich der sieht auch noch genauso
aus wie Sirio finde ich der tausenden
kleine Nase ja Leute Vorhersage ist
jetzt durch das heißt wir können
theoretisch starten beim echten Geld
auch was abgezogen
sogar du kriegst sogar Minus auf dem
Konto
ich kann nicht weiterlaufen was das für
ein scam
das Betrug ich kann nicht weiterlaufen
meine Kamera ist irgendwie total blind
oh nicht gut
wo bin ich
oder ich habe gewonnen
ich habe gewonnen ich habe 20
warte mal kommt das auf Münzen an ja da
stand da doch man muss die meisten
Münzen sammeln hey Leute Kiss marical
mit Peach Rosalina und ähm wer ist die
andere küssen
Salina Rosalinda oder wie heißt die
Nummer ja Rosalina Mary würde ich dann
natürlich Daisy und kill dann Peach weil
jemand fremdgeht ich würde es eins zu
eins genauso machen also seid ihr schon
wieder alle so da am Stern hä ich glaube
nicht sterben
holen ja zwei Verbündete das heißt sie
ist Eva mir beim Sterben weißt du was
müssen wir machen in eisigen Höhen die
höhenskulptur entstehen lassen aber wir
müssen nur drehen Siri ne ja du musst
reden bei mir lieber zu wenig ich
brauche wir haben noch übel viel Zeit
lieber das alles drauf kommen weißt du
schon gehabt
ich habe nicht mehr na ja scheiße die
waren da wieder
18,4 da kenne ich noch was
mein Armlänge sagt bereit letzte mit 12
Münzen
guck mal der wird ein Stern
ja du kannst ja Peach einem Bot von
Nintendo den Stern glaube ich oder mir
ein Kumpel von dir dem du auch noch 410
€ schuldest für den PC
400 € runtergehen Gebiete 10 € echt 400
ah überlege ich mir mhmm du bist nicht
käuflich du bist nicht goldig noch mehr
Geld bitte noch 11 € sagen wir mal so
Drink auf dich
ich gebe dir zehn Bruder
die Sache ist das ist von Sandra esgame
wir werden euch nie wieder sehen können
natürlich
besser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann ist er da ich kann einfach immer
noch keinen Stern leisten 61 Münzen
haben einfach ein G dieser Yoshi ich
habe neuen Teil Pizza und ich bin drauf
steht immer Fotos 60 München aber kein
Stern stell mal vor du hast ein Stern
aber jetzt kein Freund mehr
ich habe zwei Sterne nein nein
danke Sandra das reicht mir ja aber die
sieben Drinks
das waren sogar zehn und die Kinder
also Felder bestellen hier auf ganz
normal sicher nehmen wir jetzt den
goldenen Turbo Pilz das heißt ich habe
E-Plus 5 das heißt egal was ich Würfel
okay Leute soll ich mit Augen zu ja
okay ich habe Florentina
ah du willst doch keine Freund verlieren
warum sollte ich ihn dir nicht klauen
weil ich erkläre dir warum weil ich habe
extra Scheiße geklaut es ist einfach
Karma ja mann es ist keinmal Karma
insane man hat ja Vibration die Antwort
finden boah das ist so schwer das Spiel
[Musik]
okay interessant
ja ich glaube es war der rechts
ehrlich gesagt aber wenn ihr auf den in
der Mitte geht okay
wundert mich irgendwie das Peach das
nicht weißt warte mal
[Musik]
ich hoffe das war der das war der ganz
rechts nee nee ich denke was zu doll
glaube ich
ja
sag da haben wir wieder den ersten Platz
gerade
hat doch nicht
letzte Runde jetzt anstrengend
boah Bruder wie schwer ist exakt das
gleiche
[Musik]
ich schwöre keine Ahnung
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott ich habe
gerade ich habe geraten
aber du kannst doch gar nicht sehen ja
Leute bei sowas das hat ja nichts mit
Skill zu tun natürlich kann ich da nicht
gewinnen Geist
ich musste fünf Würfeln kommen baluigi
und ich zusammen müssen noch eine 5
hinkriegen oder
ist überhaupt keine Hilfe der Typ der
direkt beim Stern ist einfach Taktik wie
ich vorgehe beende das Spiel es war
richtig geil mit euch eine geiler Stream
und so ne aber ich bin dann jetzt auch
raus ne verstehe auch nicht warum der
immer Sterne bekommt ohne Witz aber egal
Sandra wir sind halt zu dritt Freunde
reingegangen wir gehen halt nur noch
zwei Freunde raus ja genau
solche großen Töne gespuckt nett zu
Beginn
an mir Sterne zu klauen jetzt ist zurück
geklaut wird eine Roman
Bruder
du hast doch deine Scheiße sogar du
Idiot ja was soll ich mit dem Scheiß
Röhre du bist doch direkt da mit zwei
Schritten oder bist du dumm
du nimmst direkt beim Stern raus er geht
nicht auf mich
bitte oh 50% waren auf mich 34% auf Siri
ah
auch noch von diesem bot von Rosalina
einfach was will der von mir geh doch
Typ lass mich doch allen rieren in Ruhe
Leute
Junge komm komm junge Bruder geht doch
mal zusammen
raus das war cool mit euch aber ich bin
jetzt raus hey wirklich ich gehe jetzt
offline nee warum
Digger ich kann nicht mehr gewinnen ja
doch kannst du du wolltest 20 Runden
Sandra dann müssen wir so die 20 €
machen ja Digger bin raus was macht die
da ist die Geist behindert guck ich habe
gesagt dicker deswegen
und Mario zu Hause ist geht ab es geht
ab in der Mitte oder oh ja Gott sei Dank
Ciao ja sofort
ja
also
ich werfe mal auf ganz geschmeidig
mit meinem Experia muss Würfel der eine
4 heraus
nein ich komme nein
ich habe eine Null du hast eine zwei Bro
ich fahre noch weg los
was war das nie gesehen hat der gerade
für zehn Münzen sondern Röhre eingesetzt
und nur um dann sich dahin zu
telefonieren um dann mit diesem Waggon
wieder weg Mann weißt du was passiert
ist
wir haben ja alle Bomben bekommen weil
wir durchgegangen sind ja
bzw das war Peach hat mir ja dieses
verdonnerungs Ding gegeben
man könnte ja sagen dass es vielleicht
Karma wäre eure Leistung ne
wir gehen raus an der an der es war
schön so weißt du die einfach ich habe
mich gefreut aber ja ich bin raus Leute
ich meine am Ende gibt es auch noch
immer diese Sterne die noch kommen zum
Beispiel für den der am meisten laufen
ist und so ein Scheiß ja und ich bin gar
nicht gelaufen ich habe nur die Möhre
bekommen
[Musik]
oha was ist jetzt
ja dann ist Umfrage abgebrochen ey Leute
schaut euch das mal oben rechts da an
ich habe vier Sterne und noch drei Items
ich bin beim Stern ja
[Applaus]
mach mal Augen zu habe ich
egal
oh einfach Peach geworden ey okay wer
hat von den Vorhersagen Leuten auf Peach
gegangen 3 %, die haben einfach gewonnen
ich kriege richtig Kohle jetzt die auf
Peach gegangen sind drei Felder bis zum
Sterben komm gehen wir mal auf Nummer
Sicher komm mal Luigi kannst du wieder
eine nullwürfel du Trottel dazu Leute
ganz ehrlich erholt sich den fünf fünf
Bauernhof einfach noch für mich einfach
nur noch der kommt direkt zum nächsten
Stern
guck mal wie fresh
[Applaus]
Leute nicht mehr normal dazu sage ich
gar nichts das ist nicht ich habe noch
nie noch nie eine Mario Party Runde
gesehen wo jemand sechs Sterne hatte in
der 12 Runde oder in der 13 Runde halt
also wirklich
dass das Spiel das auch nicht realisiert
dass man den Sternen nicht auf denselben
Linie liegen also wirklich dumm
programmiert ich habe sowas noch nicht
gesehen was geht gerade bei Sandra aber
eigentlich die ist rausgegangen die ist
rausgegangen nein die hat aufgelegt aber
sie ist doch live
[Applaus]
komm runter
das ist die krankeste Mario Party Runde
die ich je gespielt habe das ist so
krank es ist so krank Luca wir müssen
uns jetzt immer alles merken quasi da
merkt euch mal alles okay und Siri
stellt Fragen
Ananas Ananas Ananas es waren drei
Ananas
scheiße
wie alt ist der letzte tot
stehen ne nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein keine Ahnung
Gruppenspiel junge ja okay egal
Ananas orange Orange Zitrone Bruder
[Musik]
nein
17 17
oh mein Gott
bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte
bitte
Scheiß nicht rein bitte Scheiß nicht
rein
oha machen
natürlich weiß sie dass
natürlich
Computer wie viele Orangen
1 2 3 nein
scheiße ich habe sogar extra Screen mit
Handy gefilmt und falsch gezählt
du hast mit Handy abgefilmt
und du hast trotzdem falsch gezählt das
ist so wie wenn du ein spickerner
Klausur hast in der Englisch oder so
weil da stehen so zahlen drauf weil du
dachtest du schreibst Mathe ey wie kann
man so ein Trottel sein Klauer einem
Gegner 5 bis 10 Münzen nein Luca
nein Luca wehe
bitte weißt du was ich mache zufällig
ich mache okay zufällig zufällig sowieso
immer ich
rauskommt ja okay ja ja immer zufällig
machen nein geht dann ja wenn nicht dann
nimmt man mehr mag ja dann würde ich
Sirion nehmen
nicht mehr mögen
das ist ja total unfair wenn die jetzt
anfängt
ich denn jetzt als letztes oder
streicheln als letztes
[Musik]
die süß der guckt wenn er sauer ist ich
hätte davor früher richtig Angst guck
mal jetzt ist der bei euch schon sofort
aufgewacht der ist schon sau
[Musik]
schlau schlauer
wie lange geht denn das bist ja auch
wach
[Musik]
oh [__]
yeah es ist einfach Karma dass ihr so
schlecht seid weil ihr auch vorhin zu
Beginn meinte ja lass auf Luca gehen
dann habe ich schon Ansagen gedrückt
dass sie mich rasieren wird und so ihr
seid zu dritt ja aber Peach macht ja nix
Sandra werde ich verarscht
Sandra ja
die guckt sich den Ball erstmal 5
Sekunden an ja die liegt das Bella
anzugucken
meine insta Story packen jetzt die
krankeste Mario Party ohne dich hier
gespielt habe ne ja mann übertrieben
geisteskrank ja heftig Bruder
boah so gut hä ich bin noch viel größer
drauf gewesen
schon wieder komplett drauf ja aber ich
mache Superman fly ha ha bist
[Applaus]
bekommen die nicht mal zu sehen gewesen
bis ich mal okay Alter nein nein
gar nichts mehr machen also vor mir ich
war Geisteskranken Rampenlicht mal
heißen
ey wir haben gesagt wir machen zufällig
das weißt du ne er gibt's nicht leider
Bro hä wie wie was daran nicht zu
verstehen
gib mal ab junge also du willst mir
allen Ernstes Widerstand brauchen
natürlich wir haben gesagt wir machen
zufällig ja aber Bruder wir haben gesagt
wir machen zufällig ja oder man mag halt
jemanden nicht nein Bruder wir haben
gesagt
guck mal
ja Bruder es kann nicht sein dass wir
regeln vereinbaren und uns nicht daran
halten
vielleicht geht's doch es wird doch eh
auf mich gehen bro
[Musik]
es geht eher auf mich
zufällig
ja sehr gut wirklich gemacht
item vom Kollegen klauen entspannen oh
mein Gott du kannst ruhig klauen aber
nicht mir weil ich meine jetzt direkt
benutze
sowieso einfach nur
sehr traurig an okay -2
sind die letzten drei Runden hey guck
mal das ist die die direkt da ich checks
halt nicht guck mal Lukas direkt
darstellen trotzdem alter dicker das ist
vier Blöcke entfernt ja aber so der eine
wird nur ein zwei das heißt wenn ich 1 2
Würfel sind am Arsch vielleicht ohne
dich aber es ist krank
zwei Kollegen oh mein Gott
unseren Teil und ich mache den oberen
die obere Hälfte
okay ja die untere Hälfte also quasi
einfach gar nichts
bist so ein Trottel ne ihr habt gewonnen
du hast doch gewonnen
das lief da weil Peach immer mein Weg
war die olle nein ich kann die Röhre und
ich kaufen Digger du hast sieben sieben
Sterne was willst du noch
hey warum bin ich denn jetzt gegen die
anderen drei
[Applaus]
boah Alter habe ich Luca rasiert ja
Bruder das ist ja komplett unfair wenn
ihr zu viert seid hä ich kann einfach
Geisteskranken bro
was ergibt das für ein Sinn wenn ihr zu
viert seid
trotzdem für Siri am sinnvollsten
boah
keine Chance bei dir Bruder das ist auch
Todes unfair kann ja mal kurz erklären
wie ich die Map sehen kann
Würfeln quasi ja und dann direkt auf X
drücken Sie Rio damit du auf der 6
landest so ja
und ja du hast aber genug andere die dir
noch zwei ermöglichen denke ich mag sie
immer langweilig wie warte mal die
anderen jetzt nicht für mich das ist das
geil
so ein skel guck mal ich habe nur
Passion im Game
hey ich dachte die anderen sind auch
dabei na jetzt kommt diese Peach olle
und nimmt mir den Stern weg
ich sage gar nichts dazu
gar nicht gelohnt diese guck mal du hast
extra gemacht ne Siri ich schwöre soweit
ich stehe nein
nicht Sirius schwöre ich wusste das
nicht so war ich hier stehe wirklich ich
nehme jetzt mein item
das heißt plus 5 wo wart ihr gerade
13 das kriegt ja gar nicht hin außer ich
will das kann ja gar nicht hin muss
fünf kommt bitte Jungs
nein
ja nein
ey Bro die hatten einen mehr machen
müssen
nein was das denn was ist denn ein
Riesenfeld du kannst jetzt den Stern z.B
verlieren ja das wäre geil
ich habe doch gar keins
ungeschoren boah sehr gut
[Musik]
bin seit 3 Monaten dabei
bei dir
[Musik]
[Applaus]
30 Punkte hey der kann genauso sein das
machen wie du was okay
hoch
jetzt nein
ja unten
nein ich bin
nein
gesehen
Super Mario Party aber ich glaube
wirklich
den kleinsten Dinger Hochhaus schade
dass es nicht noch spannender wurde und
dass sie so schlecht seid naja wirklich
geil abgezogen
bis zum Stern 10 okay ja schaffst du Bro
du hast drei Helfer jeder Würfel eine 1
007 fertig wenn ich eine 7 mache und die
eins zwei dann geht ja scheiße super
super
[Musik]
die meisten Münzen eingesammelt Leute
übrigens schaut mal auf dem Laser Luca
Clips Kanal auf Youtube vorbei da werden
ganz ganz viele Clips immer hochgeladen
sehr sehr nice auch danke für den
Support haben einige Videos schon
sechsstellig Aufrufe also kurzen 10
Sekunden Videos oder so das ist sehr
geil danke schön okay Sirio jetzt
konzentrieren ja Konstruktion ne richtig
und nicht so wie Sandra ein Video machen
nein
so ein NPC ohne witz komm runter
[Musik]
echt so schlechte
erste Frage verkackt die schon ja merkst
Du selber eine Peach jemanden Browser
ein bisschen chillen
mit internet browser
der vierte getragen ich würde sagen
orange
Ananas Ananas orange Apfel Ananas orange
also auch Raketen oder wie
1 2 3 4
ach so zehn die ganzen Dinge da auch
unten ja
filmt
medica
ich hab doch gesehen doch
zum ersten Platz
oder ich würde sagen ja aber ich habe
schon verloren aber ich würde sagen
Sirio hat die meisten gewonnen
perfekt
würde ich sagen oder
Siri oh
Mann ja die läuft ja immer zu Hause
deswegen
hat schon verdient
was denn
oh Beach und serio einfach kein extra
Stern bekommen dieses Spiel ich leg auf
ey war ein geiler Stream Leute ne na na
wir gehen jetzt noch kurz in Minecraft
ja war richtig geil und so ne war jetzt
schön ne
oh wer hat wohl gewonnen
diesmal geht der Sieg an Yoshi also ähm
Sirio Kuss Bruder danke schön dass du
mit dabei warst
gerne
lieb kann ich
[Musik]